[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money and your
life i'm john dolone joined with my good
friend and best-selling author
christy wright how are you hey this is
so fun you and i haven't hosted together
in a while
have we ever hosted together yes we did
i think i blocked it out i don't
actually i don't actually know you know
i don't think we ever have i think
you're imagining things but listen
everyone wants to host with me so well
that's a fact that's actually not a fact
at all
hey listen give us a call at 825-5225
we have a packed house here everybody
came to see dave and they got me and
christy and we are excited to see it
you're welcome yes that's right triple
eight eight two five five two two five
taking your calls on life on
relationships on mental health on monday
on anything you got and um
kelly and the gang are standing by and
we are happy to see everybody it's
friday it is we're in a good mood who's
not in a good mood when it's friday and
it's beautiful outside here in nashville
all right let's go to caitlin eight
right down the street in nashville hey
caitlin what's going on
hi um you guys are the perfect people to
answer my question
okay so my question is one um i just
started my own cleaning business i quit
my full-time job because i was making
way more money doing the cleaning
business in march well way to go there
it's doing pretty
thank you it's doing really good but
um i got a second job because um we're
just trying to get out of debt really
fast or not really fast but like well
yeah really fast um
and so i was talking to my therapist
about it and like she totally was like
against it she's like it's not good for
your mental health you always live in
fight or flight mode like it's not an
emergency to get out of debt um dave
ramsey just doesn't like care about your
mental health which i know is not true
um and like so she was totally like
against me getting a second job and i
got it at a gym so it's not too hard and
um i'm it's my second week this week and
i'm really enjoying it and i got a lot
of hours last week
and like i did the math on that like we
could be out of debt in like six to
seven months
completely why did you encounter you
know you're doing charging why does she
why does she tell you not to get a
second job there's something deeper than
she just doesn't like dave
yeah well she says because like um i
just started working with her and i have
like a lot of trauma
in my um and she says that i constantly
live in the back of my brain where it's
like fight or flight and i make
everything in emergency and i always try
to fix everything for everyone and like
she says i don't know how to relax and
she sees it as being unhealthy and she's
like hold on you're saying she is she
she a lot
is is the truth in what she said
yeah like what she says is absolutely
right okay
so you you are
paying a therapist you're paying a
counselor to walk
through some challenges in your life
with you right and
you're paying this person you're walking
alongside them and they're giving you a
professional recommendation to yes get a
new job you're doing it you're you're
getting it
but based on where you happen to be
right now i'm going to recommend you
slow down a little bit
not because dave's stupid okay not
because of you know filling the play
here
but i'm going to recommend you slow down
and so your first instinct is to run
from that decision right a run from her
recommendation or his recommendation to
fight his or her recommendation right
and that puts you right it just
validates what they're trying to tell
you does that make sense
yeah and i was like trying like i mean i
want to listen to her
but you don't really want to listen to
her
but it's just like to me like the debt i
feel like is drowning me okay and like
it gives me
like so to me like it makes sense to
just work really hard for six months and
then i can enjoy the rest of my life but
like i see where she's coming from but
it's i don't know it's just really hard
for me so i just want to get out of out
as fast as possible i got that so
there's there's two sides to this number
one
if you get to the end of any finish line
and you got and you've burned out
everything
that victory is hollow right you just
created another set of challenges
and the other side of it is yeah maybe
she doesn't fully understand
maybe she doesn't fully get it
and so maybe it's a mix of both i'm
never gonna you i'm never gonna tell you
on a call on radio show to like oh
you're psychologist is an idiot you
shouldn't do that no don't do that right
so i'm always gonna tell you if you're
hiring a professional here and they're
walking alongside you um listen to your
counselor and at the same time i think
coming with some sort of um
chrissy i'm thinking some sort of
um compromise here between her therapist
you're looking at me like i'm crazy no i
just have questions i'm so anxious to
ask you let's go
okay and i wanted to make sure you
you're able to yeah so caitlin some sort
of compromise here to go with your
counselor and say hey i've decided to
take this second job and i want you to
walk alongside me and let's come up with
a couple of
um benchmarks here that we're gonna know
i'm over my head that i'm starting to
spin out i'm starting to get exhausted
i'm starting to fall back into some of
these fight or flight things some of my
default addictions those kind of things
and that you're gonna give your
counselor permission to call you out on
it okay there's one question i have in
relation to caitlyn and i think you're
talking about this but at what point are
you able to look at the fruit where um
one of the things i paid attention to
that caitlyn said is like i really enjoy
it it's like i'm happy i'm able you know
it's
you know where you can look at the fruit
and go okay it's not causing the
the outcome that she said it could cause
and then i start go oh if it starts
causing that then that's a red flag let
me pull back on my hours or whatever if
there's fruit that's positive is that a
point where you can go oh maybe this is
um like you said more of a compromise
i'm curious about that in relation to
caitlyn
you can actually get addicted chemically
to fighting and running you can get
addicted chemically to anxiety so what
that means is when things are a little
bit calm and you spin everything up or
you take another job and you say yes to
another thing and yes another thing it
can feel good in the moment right
you are hitting that that addiction yeah
like ding ding and it goes
right and same as when you have peace in
your marriage sometimes i just got to
spin up a fight here because i need the
conflict because that's what my body is
done that john i have no idea i was
looking at kelly i can't relate it
exactly so some of us and i'm talking
about myself who are addicted to the
chaos addicted to anxiety the actual
biochemistry of it will spin it up right
okay i have a question and it's not it
made me think of it when caitlyn was
talking but i think this is something
that is so relevant for every person
listening certainly anyone that's ever
been in counseling or ever planning to
be in counseling so at what point um
could you make such a good point that
you're hiring a professional for their
professional opinion
but how do you discern in the moment
that there is the possibility that
they're wrong and
i say this john can i tell a crazy story
anything you want i don't know if i'm
gonna get in trouble for this they'll
edit it later or something if so i've
never known it's live but go ahead
i've never told this story but this the
reason i ask is because there are a lot
of counselors and most are good and most
are right and most are awesome and all
that you're gonna have some right that
maybe aren't or they just don't have the
full context or they're you know they're
going by the script or they're training
and they're not considering the full
picture or the the client's not being
honest or whatever so this is the crazy
story
matt and i when we were um dating and
engaged we went to premarital counseling
of course through someone that was um
yeah totally through a counselor and
someone that was recommended from
recommended whatever we didn't know i
mean we you know we didn't have
counselors at that point and um and she
was fine we'll come back to this in a
minute she was fine but there was one
thing she said that made me go
i don't think you're right so we'll
circle back to that oh cliffhanger i
can't wait to hear your answer on this
anger it's segment one right here hey
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're talking
relationships life love
money everything right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show and we are back
i'm john delonia joined here by christy
wright and we're taking your calls on
relationships on life on business
on your money triple eight eight two
five five two two five and at the break
you were telling us uh you asked me a
question about when do you know
that you are with the wrong counselor
right yeah like
how do you discern the possibility that
they're wrong and so my scenario is matt
and i were in premarital counseling and
this is we were dating and it was a
referral from a referral or so on and so
delena so she met with us a couple times
together
and then she wanted to do a session with
us each separately and so in my session
with her we're talking about matt and
i's personalities and our you know just
different things
and she looks at me john and she goes
it's not too late
you haven't walked down the aisle yet
like she literally started advising me
not to marry matt and like bless her but
like
matt and i don't have a perfect marriage
but he's the man for me like god created
us for each like like we have a
wonderful marriage so she was just wrong
okay she was just wrong there and i felt
it in my spirit yes you know because i
was like yeah i'm gonna not heed that
advice because i just i don't think
you're on point you know and so that's
an extreme example and i know it's
ridiculous that our premarital counselor
told us not to get married we have a
great marriage and and i just feel like
she just didn't get the memo from god
that we actually were supposed to be
married um but but regardless of the
situation where you have someone very
well meaning and very well trained
that's advising someone and of course
when you're the client
uh that can be hard like well to your
point they're the professional and so
what about what about when they're not
what about when they're not i mean not
professional but not not right maybe it
has to happen sometimes yeah so there's
a few things that i keep in mind one is
like right when you said that i'm
thinking of
[Music]
what what a marriage a premarital
counselor's advice is to give you all
some tools and some skills
and then to enter into a relationship
with you and oftentimes if you've never
been to a counselor if you don't know
what that is you think i'm going to go
somewhere didn't listen and they're just
going to spit out some advice for me and
that's not what that is what it is is
practicing how to be in a relationship
with somebody and they'll ask you
questions and make you think about
things and give you assignments that
you're going to work on at home and
things and so i'm thinking
if i was doing premarital counseling i
would say hey it's not too late and if
your gut rises up and says oh
for sure he is
then you know and if you went home and
thought
you're right this isn't too late and so
she goes why did you choose them i go
cause god told me whoa
she was like okay well i guess we're
done here i'm gonna tell my wife that
because i think she's still wondering
what did i do right but i think to your
point the discernment process if you're
asked if your counselor tells you to do
something that is outside your moral
balance obviously that's ridiculous if
somebody has listened to your story and
says i think
like
a second job
is too much for sure yeah i think this
person's not for you here's what i would
do i wouldn't fight the counselor i'd go
talk to somebody that i trust and say
hey i'm meeting with a therapist then
gave me
some wild advice right and use that as a
relational leverage
if um somebody misses the boat
completely or tells you something stupid
yeah walk away and my big thing is it's
all about gut feeling yeah and because
it's a relationship if you walk in after
a session or two you're like or three i
always ask people to say three or four
i'm not clicking i don't trust you
yeah i don't feel like i can fully yeah
just speak my mind here my heart here
then go find somebody else well i think
it's relevant for people that are that
are in counseling and they're going hey
is this advice on point you know in this
example type of thing so i think if
you're getting a lot of advice for
account from a counselor that's a
problem forgetting a lot of advice from
a counselor right it's it's going to be
some recommendations and some
assignments and discussion that's good
ashley in buffalo new york hey ashley
what is going on
um hi um i'm kind of going to graduate
college this year um and i'm like really
lucky i was a computer science major in
college you're kind of going to graduate
or you for sure are
i'm definitely gonna
stand up ashley you are in buffalo new
york and you are going to graduate right
yes sir yeah good don't say sir i'm not
that old
okay so you are going to graduate
and you're an i.t major right
um yeah like um computer science yes
yeah the i.t is the way we said it back
in the 1400s you are computer science is
the right way okay so what's your
question how can help
um so the thing is that um i'm i'm
really lucky i'm gonna at least be
making 90k a year because like that's
the current offer i have i'm gonna have
to like keep looking for other jobs but
um my i'm really lucky like through
financial aid scholarships and my
parents i'm gonna graduate with no debt
but um i kind of told my parents a long
time ago you kind of told them or you
did tell them
um i did tell them she's kind of done a
lot of things yes okay you told them
that i would probably pay back whatever
they paid for school for me okay um
which should probably be around 50k um
depending on how much i make this year
and how much i contribute with my
part-time job um
so
i don't know if after graduation i
should kind of go in the debt snowball
first or if i should like do the
emergency fund i'm just kind of not sure
so number one don't kind of do anything
ever again you are too smart and too
um talented to kind of do things
is that cool
yeah okay good all right here's the
second thing do you know for sure
i couldn't tell do you owe your parents
this money or not was this like a
statement that an 18 year old said like
i'll pay you back and they're like oh
great and they're counting on this money
or are you gonna sit down and have to
and they're gonna say no you're not
paying us back like what what's the
actual status here
the actual debt is i don't have to pay
them back but my brother's special needs
like very severely special needs and
they kind of don't have a lot of money
for retirement if that makes sense and
he's not going to college so i kind of
feel like the internal need to pay them
back if that makes sense
it makes sense um and christy i love
your thoughts here actually my gut
reaction is i would love for you to sit
down with your mom and dad and say i
made a commitment to you guys told
y'all's gonna pay y'all back
and what would this actually look like
for us
it's not your responsibility to
take care of your parents financially at
this point you're not you're you haven't
even graduated college yet if they come
to you at some point say hey we need
help with your special needs brother
that's a whole other conversation here
but right now you have put yourself in
the position of being their financial
backup plan and that's that's not your
job not your role that's their
responsibility
what i would love to see you do is to
sit down and clarify your financial role
with them and then
begin
going through paying off any debts you
have you graduate debt-free that's
incredible and then you're gonna take
this
awesome salary because you're talented
and brilliant and then you're gonna be
off to the races
yeah i think um clear communication with
your parents ashley's gonna be huge so
you just sit down and say hey i really
wanna do this i'm gonna create a budget
that allows me to live on half of what
i'm making and i'm going to pay you guys
back super fast it's something i want to
do i know i don't have to do it but i
want to do if you do and you guys get on
the same page and just um you clearly
communicate that the other thing i know
we joked with you ashley but seriously i
want you
to practice not saying kind of because
when you say kind of you sound young and
insecure and you're not insecure and you
will instantly project more confidence
that will then become real confidence
when you take out weak words i i talk to
women about this all the time it's not
just kind of it's also i mean
i just
i'm sorry i have a question when we act
pitiful it does something to our sense
of self and so i want to help you um
truly practice this it's just a habit
you don't mean to we all say things we
don't realize we do
but that's going to help you in the
workforce and it's going to help you in
life so work on practicing catching
yourself taking out kind of i mean i
just you know these weak words and it's
going to help you build confidence and
project that really intelligent young
woman that's in there which you are i
just want people to be able to see that
so i that's my second assignment in
addition to the money question but i
love it i think you're gonna do it
you're gonna be great all right
gabrielle in bangor maine what's up
gabriel
hi i'm so nervous so bear with me sorry
hey we're nervous too we don't know what
we're doing so hey how can we help
um yeah so actually my dad just decided
to take out a loan for his family
he wants it to be a family business um
and i'm excited to do it with him but um
i don't know if i should but i'm not
going to be doing it for like six months
um because he needs to get that set up
on his on his own he's that type of
person
um but
he's not saying that i need to but
should i be helping him pay for the loan
absolutely not
okay no if your dad is running a
business and he's deciding to take out a
business loan when you say you're
helping him can you explain that are you
an employee are you a partner are you a
co-owner
well um
well i right now it would just be i
guess an employee but he wants to in
about six months like
it's
planned to do well enough where i could
just leave my job and make way more
money working with him yeah you need to
put in the arrangement that you're not
paying this debt regardless of your
title or role but make sure it's clear
and it's on paper and if you're going to
become a partner to his business you all
have to be on the same business
principles following the same plans and
have the same philosophy towards how
you're going to handle your money right
no this is not your debt to pay off what
in any shape form or fashion right here
on the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show and we are back
and we have two beautiful people
standing on the debt-free stage rob and
jill from marietta georgia how are we
doing great great i'm assuming since
you're standing on the so named
debt-free stage that you are debt-free
how much have you paid off we have paid
off a hundred and fifty thousand wow way
to go you guys thank you how much how
long did it take you to pay this off it
took us 30 months so we started january
of 2019 okay and finished about
about three months ago okay 30 months
how much were you making during this
time uh started at 187
and uh ended at 2 14. nice oh what do
you do for a living so we're i'm the
first practitioner yep she's a nurse
practitioner and he's a nurse yep i like
how you said that right just so we all
know yeah she's smarter than me there
you go yeah there's a hierarchy here we
see it we see it i stay in my place so
what in the world happened 30 months ago
that y'all too said we've got to do this
now well uh in october of 2018 a couple
of things happened we
[Music]
thought we were doing the right thing
went and sat down with some friends um
some friends recommended an investment
company goodwin investments
sat down with some guys there and
they uh ended up being a smart investor
pro
and um
they said you have an elephant in the
room that you need to escort out before
you can invest you know nicely
meaning our and fifty thousand of
student loans and two cars wow so before
you can invest we'd like for you to
consider this plan so um
so they they looked at you and said we
don't want your money until your life is
clear yeah and
immediately i was sold on you know the
company because they i mean they could
have just you know we had a great income
obviously so
um but he said just consider this i'm
not saying no but this is a plan and um
and you know i kind of sell the kool-aid
as it were
as a smart buster so um the other thing
that happens we sat down with our really
good friends chris and amy
um
and uh they're smarter than us
they're they're smarter than us have
they've seen a lot more life and
they looked at our five almost 600 car
payment and said this is a choice
but um this is what we've done
so uh it was just kind of a
a moment and then in february of that
same year we had had our first little
girl so awesome all of a sudden you know
you're looking at other yeah reasons
yeah different ball games so when you
all said i'm so curious when y'all sat
down with this smart buster pro and they
present this plan to you
had y'all ever heard of the baby steps
or dave ramsey or anything unfortunately
i had okay
well sometimes it can be one of those
shocking things of like a life without
debt i've never considered that and and
usually it's a family or friend or
someone that kind of gives you their
testimony and that is a word of mouth
referral but to have it from a
professional like just kind of in this
quick meeting that's interesting that
you guys you know were really receptive
to it that's really cool well in 2002 to
let's see no it would have been 2004 to
2006 with my church we lived in rome at
the time rome georgia um we um
were introduced to the to this concept
but dave was stupid because he was
telling me to not take out student loans
and i was taking out student loans to go
to private college right so a lot of
student loans so um obviously he was
dumb he did not know what he was talking
about at all it was not for us we were
an exception so
um when he brought it up i said wow this
is
again you know another wisdom piece from
god and jill right away you were on
board absolutely not
hey i love dishonesty right here you're
a nurse practitioner you're gonna drive
what you wanna drive you're gonna live
right i make all this money why am i not
buying this and doing what i wanna do
and going on this vacation
yeah buying a house we've been living in
the same tiny little house so halfway
through this journey you have an almost
two-year-old
and then the world shuts down and looks
at you two and says help right walk us
through how you kept going through that
mayhem
you don't have a choice right that's
your job so you just
keep going every day you're like going
to work going okay here we are luckily i
mean i work in an office so it's not as
bad but i do go to the hospital and i
see all that and
it's just
crazy but you guys kept making a budget
every month you kept doing it every
month yeah who are your biggest
cheerleaders
so yeah shout out to chris and amy
obviously that we mentioned them already
brandon and kristen um
our small group we're in a great small
group been in for years um all of my
friends because the people i work with
we constantly talk about our journey it
was kind of our way of i guess
keeping us on track talking about it and
obviously i'm thankful for jill
she was i'm the nerd i'm the spreadsheet
guy yeah she's the dreamer
so i'm just thankful for her for
sticking with me and and um i didn't
want to but we did it yep yep we did it
together what would you tell people just
met you on the street what's the key to
getting out of debt um well if you
choose this plan uh you need to stay on
it um
you need to read the book um go through
the nine week class we did in person i'm
not sure what that looks like now with
um you know our world
meeting in person but um the podcast was
huge for me uh listening to people's
stories that had more debt and less
money to work with um the podcast is
what i lived and breathed you know i can
bring your why why you're doing it yeah
remember in our why are sitting
yeah that's incredible so have you had a
month yet where
the check's deposited and you've got no
bills
yes yeah a couple i think yeah and and
it's it's we're
smiling for those you're listening crazy
well all of a sudden you're like what do
i do with this extra money oh yeah 3a
and 3b you know
yeah we still rent or yeah so okay very
cool yeah and so hey listen we've got a
copy of the legacy journey because
that's your next step here you're on
you're on the road to becoming everyday
millionaires and we're gonna give you a
copy of total money makeover so you can
bless somebody else with it you can give
it to somebody who's just chit-chatting
about their problems and you can tell
them about their elephant and let's
bring this beautiful beautiful lucy up
and how old is lucy lucy's three and a
half uh she's been practicing
so we will see if uh lucy performs here
right so we've got rob and jill
and beautiful lucy from marietta georgia
paid off a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in 30 months making about a
hundred and eighty seven thousand
dollars to two hundred fourteen thousand
dollars and they are now debt free rob
and jill count it down say it with me
lou ready
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that's amazing that's really really cool
that's a huge amount of debt but it's
just amazing where when you decide when
you decide like we're sick and tired of
being sick and tired we've been trying
this it hasn't worked we've got to try
something different man you never look
back once you stand where they're
standing right now where you feel the
feeling of not having those payments so
let's average this let's take
200 000 it's a great income yeah it's a
great income
a little over
about two and a half years right
150 dollars yeah and so sometimes you
fall into a trap you make a good salary
you think right i deserve this car yeah
i deserve a house that looks like this
it needs to be mine and then i needed to
add on to it and fill in the blanket
fill in the blank
and man rob and jill
sucked it up for two years two and a
half years and that little girl lucy
man she reminds me of my little girl i
kept it's just she's so so precious
she's never gonna know the 150 000
elephant in the middle of a living room
right yep because mom and dad said no
and the decisions that they make in six
months and six years and 16 years are
gonna be so different because there's no
debt determining those decisions it's
whatever decisions they want to make
with the cash that they have
and the freedom and that's what i want
people to understand this is not just
about money that we teach we're talking
about your future your options when
you've got money you've got options when
you've got stuff you don't have any
options
they don't get you anything when you
have a spouse when you've got a partner
in life that you've gone through two and
a half years of we're just gonna be
weirdos in the trenches and then you
come to the other side and you've
completed this incredible goal
then you think we can do anything yeah
we can
have to deal with mom and dad struggling
we can deal with you know economic
issues we can deal with you know we got
to change churches whatever the thing
that pops up in your pay for lucy's
college like whatever there's just so
many more options college will be 11
million dollars
they could possibly have it by the way
they could figure it out that's right
i wish folks could understand y'all
listen to this on the podcast there's
something about being in here every time
and every time i think i see a little
kid i see a couple that's made it i
think back to my marriage i think back
to my little kids i know you do the same
and it's inspiring every single time
people ask me about working here and i
tell them it's like working in a glitch
in the matrix right you get to be
reinspired every time i come to work by
amazing folks like robin jill little
lucy she's doing laps on the stage right
now this is so amazing guys thanks for
blessing us thanks for blessing up the
country
what an incredible journey guys we're
talking to you
you have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar elephant in the middle of your
living room you can make your change and
you can start today
start today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
are you feeling overwhelmed or stretched
too thin
i've been there
after being on all day at work at home
and with my kids i used to feel like i
was running on empty two and let's be
honest sometimes i still get there we
all do
here's the deal balance is something
that you can create in your life you
don't have to be overwhelmed by this
elusive idea of balancing everything all
the time perfectly
you can actually create your own version
of balance and that comes from doing the
right things at the right time and the
great news is you get to decide what's
right for you that's exactly why i
created my new book take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
which by the way is on pre-sale for one
more week which means you've got one
week to go ahead and get your copy
and then you get all the free uh bonus
items i was listening to them rattle off
the bonus items it's like we're gonna
come roof your house and give you a swim
it's incredible
you get the ebook you get the audio book
you get a ticket to my event on
september 16th live stream uh here from
nashville me and dave ramsey are
speaking you also get access to a
private facebook community with me and
so it's our way of saying thank you for
um getting your order in early so you
guys have got another week to do that we
will still ship it on launch day which
which is uh september 14th
and uh and when you do you will be
helping us with our marketing which we
appreciate which is why we give you
those bonus items here's the thing john
i am have started seeing reviews come in
which is like the greatest dude it's the
greatest feeling as an author because oh
yes it's connecting
and what's really cool i saw one today
and and the woman said this book has
allowed me to take a deep breath
and i thought that was really cool
because that's the heart behind it this
is not a book about how to do more it's
about how to do what's right for you
yeah and actually experience freedom in
your life and and i think that's really
powerful so get your copy take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance you've got one week to get your
pre-order and you get all the free stuff
i can't think of a book that is more
timely more needed in a season where you
know what's gonna be two weeks to
flattening the curve an hour a year and
a half later
to
everyone's had to do everything
and then there's industries that popped
up telling you what everything's
supposed to look like and there's the
right way to do everything
and to be able to get your hands on i
love that
piece right and we throw that word
around a lot we don't know what that
actually means it means dropping your
shoulders to get a breath well it's so
foreign to us i mean we walk around all
of us not just women not just parents
you walk around with your shoulders up
by your ears your chest is tight all the
time this is what you talk about with
anxiety and man some of it is the
culture and some of it is outside of our
control but man some of it is within our
control some of it is pressure we put on
ourselves a lot of this yeah just just
helping people understand why they do
what they do it's not the way i've been
saying it lately is that this is not
just about the calendar it's about
enjoying the life that the calendar
represents and i want to help you do
that and so we've got to get to the root
issue if we're going to fix it at the
root level and not have it keep creeping
up in the same way i'm so glad you wrote
this book that's such a needed thing
good for you
and high five to you that
there's nothing more terrifying than
putting a book out there and no the
reviews come in i know and you're like
you're like holding your breath you're
like is it good are they gonna like are
they gonna get it is it gonna connect
and so yeah that's been fun to see the
last few days
i thought that when when we were out of
elementary school i would answer i would
stop asking the question do they like me
and still
do they like me
and there's millions of people right now
that were just like nope we don't know
all right let's go today we never see
that's gonna happen in fairbanks hey
abby in alaska what's going on
um hi thanks for taking my call you
betcha what's going on how can i help
how can we um so
so i'm taking
the foundations class for high school
the high school one
um and i'm just learning about like
um different ways i can pay for college
and one of them is community
and i've i'm going into medical school
so i'm just wondering like what my
options are financially like what's the
best option so what what grade are you
in now
i'm a senior you're a senior in high
school or college
high school senior in high school and
what do you want to do medical school
um i either want to be a pa or a nurse
practitioner so you're thinking more
nursing school
um
a program like that
versus medical school which would be you
want to be a doctor or a surgeon or
something like that
yeah so there's a number of different
options and and i guess i guess at the
root of your call you're asking how do
you how in the world can you do nursing
school debt-free right
yeah yeah
um so it starts on a foundation of a
debt-free undergraduate degree
right you're going to make that's going
to be a
commitment that you're going to make i
will not go into debt that means i'm
going to start at a community college if
i have to that means i'm going to go to
in
state i'm going to apply for every grant
every scholarship i compile i'm going to
make that a second and third job right
i'm not going to go into debt for
undergraduate and then when you head
into nursing school there's several
different options here sometimes you can
graduate and go work
and get an undergrad a bachelor's degree
in nursing and go work and you can work
for a place that will
put you through
nursing school i mean to get your your
master's in nursing or in your pa degree
you can do that you can work along the
way and take night school and pay for it
along the way you can go work and be a
nurse with a bachelor's degree for a few
years and save up and do it there's a
number of different ways i want you to
focus your first next couple of years on
making sure you graduate with your
undergraduate degree debt free
and then begin researching places that
are going to support you in your work
right now agency nursing has exploded
there's all over the place you're going
to have a million different options here
but i want you to focus i want you to
take the right steps in the right order
yeah the thing i would say abby that i
love that john's telling you just think
of this because you're thinking long
term and i love that i love that you're
thinking long term you will make
different decisions now
in your undergrad than you would because
you know you want to go to this
additional education so for example if i
were you i would try to get as many
scholarships as i can
to pay for your undergrad so that when
you work during undergrad you're
stockpiling that cash for your
additional education whereas if you work
to pay through school what you can do
it's going to be hard to stockpile cash
in addition to paying for your undergrad
cash you can do some combination of this
but i'll tell you time spent
looking for scholarships which so many
people get intimidated by there's
fascinating research on what you average
per hour most people think oh i'm just
going to sign my name to a loan because
that's all i can do um one guy i
actually um got to know and interviewed
years ago john when i first started
working for this company
he searched and searched and searched
for scholarships and he averaged out
afterwards the amount of hours he spent
searching for scholarships and the
amount of money he he made and he
averaged 900 an hour wow that's there's
not a part of the world that's right
that will pay you that so it's worth the
work to search and apply and search and
apply and write essays abby do that i
would do that as much as you can for
undergrad and certainly for your
additional education but start there and
then when you work during undergrad you
get to keep all that money for the most
part and i want to add that if you can
abby get a job at a local hospital get a
job at a local um
at a blood bank some place where you can
be around the profession because they're
gonna also have different they're gonna
have insider information on oh that
nursing school helps you this way yeah
this job will pay for your master's
degree so start now have four years of
working in the medical profession and
make sure you get out debt-free and then
the other avenues are going to begin to
open up especially if you put in the
time you'll learn more about what you
want to do about it exactly right and
you may go in for a year and be like
whoa i'm not doing this i'm going to do
something else that's right all right
let's go to bk in calgary hey bk guess
we're up against the clock so get right
to your question
hi uh hi both of you uh my story is
pretty magical and the magic uh was
bought by uh dave ramsey i started
listening to him uh back in 2013. i paid
off about 150 000 in about 38 months
back then
but then life happened uh we moved to
canada uh i got a baby boy and during
medical expenses and everything we were
debt free at the time so we wiped out
our savings and i've got about seven
thousand dollars in credit card debt
that i'm working uh multiple jobs to pay
off good deal
maximum name abk we're right up against
the clock so we'll get right to your
question yeah here we go
thank you
you guys uh i'm actually also trapping
uh
uh an e-commerce company on the side i
started with two thousand dollars uh
it's roughly about eight it's just my
savings that i'm trying to uh build up
the company with not trying to borrow
i've got about uh 47 000
in consumer debt out of which 42 is a
car which i need for my
jobs and other things that i do
so here's the thing brother um number
one you don't need a 42 000 car you need
to sell your car and get out of debt
sell your car and get out of debt and if
your question is should you pay off your
consumer debt before you start funding a
hobby a side business what's the answer
yes yes pay your debts off start this
side hustle debt
free right and never go back into debt
again bk you know better life happened
you can do it this has been the ramsay
show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money your life
your business your relationships
everything you can think of and more
give us a call at
825-5225 i'm john deloney joined here
with my good friend and best-selling
author
and author of the soon to be released
rockstar book take back your time
christy wright and we are taking your
calls on pretty much anything you can
come up with triple eight eight two five
five two two five christy how are we
doing great it's friday i'm telling you
i love front i love hosting on fridays
because everybody's in a good mood
getting ready for the weekend i love it
that makes it what are you doing this
weekend
i don't know um
that's kind of a good feeling it's yeah
i
mean not having any plans that's kind of
nice you know it's like okay let's just
see what happens i think we've got plans
i just i'm not that far i need to get
through this we should yeah that's how
you roll you and i live differently we
do what are you doing this weekend
uh taking the boys to a football game
tonight and then going to the lake
tomorrow it's our last lake weekend so
i'll live it up and then you're gonna
shut it down and then we're gonna shut
it down
i will probably do some mowing tomorrow
so when i'm out there mowing i will
think of the right family and they're
having a good time
it should be a blast
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a shout and we look forward
to talking to you let's go to dylan in
indianapolis indiana hey dylan what's
going on brother
so
um a few months ago i bought my first
car for 5900 all cash and i was
wondering
if it would now be
a good choice to buy a second car or a
new car
trade in that one because
the first car
um it's starting to appear that it might
have problems with rush that could have
been in a flood
and i didn't know if it would be a good
choice to do that
how old are you man
17. 17. how'd you come up with 5900
to buy your first car with cash
um part-time jobs over a couple years
i'm good for you man dude you're awesome
gavin way to go man i don't think i
could have kept 59 dylan oh dylan i'm
sorry yeah dylan
i'm not good at reading dylan
um my job actually is to keep him on
track dylan i'm here for you yeah that's
a that's a hard job so dylan you bought
a car and what what makes you think it
was in a flood or are you having buyer's
remorse did you buy a car and allison
you don't like it
tell me what no i still i still love the
car and if i were to get a new car it
would just be a newer version of it it's
a honda civic okay and i like it do you
have the money
um if i were to sell the car
at the price of it right now is around 8
000 and i would look to buy a car for
between 10 and 11 000 so add about two
three thousand dollars on to what i sell
this for and you do you have it though
yes you have that cash
yes
yeah i don't know i mean i don't have a
problem with you selling your car and
buying a new car with cash
um i wouldn't keep two cars around and i
would not um
i wouldn't be dishonest in your sale
right i would if you think there's a
problem with it if you think there's a
challenge with it i'd have it go get
looked out by a certified mechanic and
not just pass
pass your purchasing decision onto
somebody else
um obviously you want to do everything
above board yeah i don't have a problem
with that you're paying cash i mean
here's the thing dylan you're asking the
right questions most 17 year olds are
not asking that question you're paying
for in cash it's great yeah do it
absolutely good for you man
no parent
christy that's talking to us right no
parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency but teaching your teens
how to be smart with money can feel like
a big job
lucky for you we've got your back with
our digital self-study courses you can
rest assured that your teen will know
the right way to handle money no matter
what curveballs life may throw at them
down the road
and the best part no instructor needed
if your teen has a tablet or a computer
they're all set you know what that
sounds like music to a
parent's ears right now no instructor
needed especially those who are still
having to do school from home parents
text self study to 33789
that's self study to 33789 to learn more
about all of the different courses we
have available for your middle or high
schooler very cool so many of you say i
wish i knew this when i was younger
here's your chance pass it on when did
you learn about money
when i was up to my eyeballs in debt in
my mid-20s and i realized something had
to change
i mean i truly was not taught yeah money
debt say i mean i guess like you know in
passing but not no one ever sat me down
and said like here's what this really is
and so i was the typical sign up for a
free t-shirt get a credit card college
student and so i got myself into a mess
when i was in my early 20s but it was
like by degrees
i didn't oh the minimum payments 24 it's
you're literally your statistic and then
in my middle
middle my 20s i remember there was a
month i had to call my mom and ask her
to put money in my bank account and i
was so humiliated
because i was a 24 year old woman and i
couldn't support myself i wasn't
independent i value independence i
wanted to be financially independent and
it was that moment that i was like
something needs to change once i finally
faced my bills i wrote it all out on my
debts and this was even before i knew
dave ramsey i was like i just have to
get rid of this and then i got the book
and got on the plan and all the stuff
but um i literally learned like so many
uh so many college dudes so many
americans the hard way by like oh man
this sucks i work really hard and i
still can't make my payments yeah
i remember graduating from college i
remember in high school
a guy at my local church stood up and
said um
i just got laid off and people were
talking about it but i want children i'm
okay i've started doing this
thing and this was this is when
financial peace was in its infancy
and i remember that in the fast forward
six seven years later i took my first
big job after college making great money
and i ended that first year making great
money in more debt than when i started
just because i got in the habit of not
saying no you're going to remember going
what in the how did that happen well you
made a really good point though because
i don't want people to miss this you
were talking about this earlier um today
and that is when we get a promotion when
we get a raise we upgrade our lifestyle
even if
even if we have debt so like in your
example i'm making great money and i
ended up in more debt than i was in
because we think oh wow i got a new job
or oh i got a new raise i'm going to go
get a nicer car get a nicer house buy
this stuff because i deserve it but the
truth is if you're in debt you don't own
any of that stuff you owe on all of it
you're actually in the red yeah so like
it was getting redder by the year yeah
yeah
we've got to change the mindset that oh
i deserve it or i'm you know when i need
to upgrade my lifestyle matt and i from
the time that we moved in our house uh
you know we were newly married
for any raise that we've gotten or any
you know he's had different job changes
i've had different you know good years
and lower years whatever
we haven't upgraded our lifestyle and
and so the margin just increases which
gives you again power to invest to give
to make choices about where you send
your kids to school colonies and therapy
and i can afford that and it's simply
because we've maintained the margin but
you have to create it that means that
when you get a raise you don't upgrade
your lifestyle and that can be hard it
takes discipline but it's going to give
you power and control i think my wife is
wondering why i think we're
like we keep downshifting our lifestyle
every time she's like john please
that car let's don't drive horses to
work anymore can we get a car
that's so cool yeah if you can hang
tight right it just gives you so much
freedom in your life that's incredible
eight eight two five five two five give
us a shout we are here i'm john delonie
joined with christy wright on the ramsay
show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john dalone joined here by
christy wright let's go out to gavin in
cleveland ohio hey gavin what's going on
hey guys how are you outstanding brother
how are you
i'm doing very well very cool what can
we do
for you um
i'm calling to ask about my situation so
me and my wife um we just got married
recently and um we have about
thirty six thousand dollars together in
student loans but i also got a truck
last year and that's about thirty two
thousand so i was thinking about
selling it because i was looking at the
baby steps and i'm thinking that if i
sell the truck i should be able to pay
everything off and be debt free within
the next two years
uh how much do you make man
i make about
2300 a month after tax
you make 2 300 a month after tax
you have a 32 000 truck
yeah exactly well it was like what you
guys were talking about earlier
upgrading your
your lifestyle after i get a raise and
stuff i mean i couldn't make this it was
it's just because i could make the
payment i was in a small car and i
should have paid it off as before i knew
any better oh yeah i hate you and
everybody else this umbrella is so
normal same thing that they was it a
little little car
yeah i was driving a chevy cruze i had
been in for the last four or five years
dude i had an 88 tercel easy hatchback
same it's like a fred flintstone car man
and it felt so good getting that big
truck didn't it
it did it felt great what's that truck
payment every month
um the payments were 640 a month i
refinanced it but then again i stumbled
upon the baby steps and everything and
it seems like it's just a smarter idea
to sell it especially with the market
now yeah and then um you know maybe put
in a little bit more or you know maybe
get a smaller personal loan because i
have to drive a lot for work because i'm
in the construction trade so i'm all
over cleveland ohio um no do you have
any cash
yeah you have any cash
no we have the cash saved for just for
the baby step number one
um but not for
the extra money for the car i mean i
would get some money back from the truck
i'm selling it though
oh you would
yeah but maybe about two or three
thousand dollars then i would use that
to get you to get you a small truck
we're not gonna take out any more loans
gavin you're gonna be the guy rolling up
to the job site and people gonna look at
you
like you've got four eyes
okay
you're gonna sell this truck before the
day is over or at least before the
weekend is over and you're gonna go buy
a two or three thousand dollar car two
three thousand dollar truck and you're
gonna suck it up and you're gonna save
that money you're gonna get that thirty
six thousand dollars paid off as quickly
as possible and this is gonna be your
uh your stupid tax when you're driving
this car around and it's gonna man you
are gonna hustle to get this student
loan paid off right oh yeah for sure i
picked up a part-time job on the
weekends too so i should be making
excellent 600 bucks a month excellent
excellent excellent go get it go get it
go get it but yeah brother sell this
truck before the weekend is over and
never go into debt again and dude
don't go take out a small person alone
and get another car
don't do it don't do it
don't upgrade just call it well and just
think about when you get rid of this
payment and you have a paid for three
thousand dollar car
that payment now goes to chipping away
at that debt and you're gonna make so
much more progress don't add to the debt
when you don't have to and you don't
have to you don't have to all right
let's go to jessica in jacksonville
florida hey jessica what's going on
hey guys how are you guys great what's
up
i am calling because
me and my husband actually bought a
vehicle
a chevy silverado two years ago
2019 to be accepted
we finished paying it off
earlier this year we paid off 21 000
within a year and a half
of having the vehicle
but now my husband wants to sell it
because he wants a smaller
vehicle that weighs less than gas
and
i don't know if
we should sell
you clearly do not want to sell it do
you
no because actually
with the truck
i we worked two jobs
and we were paying we were making double
the payments every month
and then when we saved up like about
like it was about 12 000
we just paid off the trust just like
that sure so jessica this is not a math
problem this is a marriage problem
it's not a problem it's a marriage
discussion it's not a math problem if
you want to sell this truck and you all
decide to sell the truck you own this
thing outright you'll probably do pretty
well in the market right now and y'all
can buy a smaller car and you could
probably buy two small cars and split it
up
um
you don't want to sell this thing
why don't you want to sell it do you
like driving it or are you proud of the
two of you for saving up and paying it
off
i think that i'm proud of having this
vehicle be the first and the last
vehicle that we were going to have in
alone
and
i don't know like i just feel that if
we sell it then we lose everything that
we paid for because
we paid 21 for the truck
but when we went to a dealer they
offered 16. so i'm open to selling it
but i'm not open to just give it out for
16 000. well i mean jessica we we
recommend you sell this private party
and you're going to get a lot more money
than you would at a trading a dealership
for sure you may even get close to what
um what you paid for it because the
market is so crazy right now with
inventory being low and used car the
values are up especially if it's in good
shape so don't let that deter you you
just gotta do a little bit more homework
and research put a really get really
good photos get it cleaned up list it
private party and then you will get more
money but i appreciate your honesty
because often we will make
decisions
financial decisions based on emotional
basis it's like well we work for this it
represents what we worked for even
though
things have changed and you may or may
not need it or want it right now and
it's like oh but i need to hold on to
this because what it represents for me
and sentimental value yeah yeah so i
mean you guys do what's right for you
just like you know you were saying
deloney it's a it's a marriage
conversation and decision um but you
guys have the money you're gonna be fine
financially either way but i would
recommend selling at private party to
get more so let's say you sell a private
party and you come out uh straight
across twenty one thousand
days someone writes your chat for twenty
one thousand dollars
jessica to your point you haven't lost
everything you worked for
you and your husband did something
knucklehead together you took out a loan
for a truck
and then you all worked together you
worked really hard and you accomplished
this cool goal and what you did as
you're as a as a couple as you leveled
up you realized we can dig ourselves out
of a hole that we've created for
ourselves by working really hard being
the same team creating a goal dumping a
bunch of money into something and making
it happen so you haven't lost this thing
and if you get 21 000 and choose to roll
back off and buy a 15 000 car now you've
got money to go in towards other debts
and other things
i
lean away from
sentimentalizing is that the right word
stuff i just it's a car as a car as a
car and at the same time man i say that
to act all tough i really over
sentimentalize things like that's like
oh but this is the time and you know
what i mean so i back away from that
thing jessica what you all did together
as a couple is great and it's not about
the car it's about what you all
accomplished as a couple and if you want
to keep the truck you can just tell them
hey honey we're not selling this thing
yeah you you still accomplished it yeah
it does not negate that at all uh delay
i'm curious because you have worked with
couples for a long time how do you help
couples that are just at a standstill in
a decision making about anything they
just see it different it's to ask the
question i said is this about the truck
or is this about what's it really about
what is the feeling here and one person
has a feeling that says
i it represents shame i shouldn't have
done this i worked really hard 24 months
to pay this thing off and now just
stares at me and the drive was a
reminder i'm an idiot and then for
somebody else no this thing symbolizes
what we can do right and so it has
nothing to do with the truck it has
everything to do with the meaning we're
putting on this dumb car yeah we so
often get uh you know people call in and
say how do i get my spouse on board how
do i get myself some board and we hear
it with money the debt snowball we hear
with business i'll have women call me
hey how do i get my spouse on board with
my business dream or whatever and i just
always think that's interesting because
um because it is hard in marriage you
face decisions from gosh matt and i
we're at a standstill about where to put
the fence in our yard like the stupidest
stuff all the way up to big stuff like a
car or you know a business and so i'm
just gonna tell you matt right now
you can fight it brother but you're
gonna end up putting that fence wherever
christy wants it he won that one he
totally won that one yeah he was right
and he was right he won
christy he lost
he was matt
balls matt you lost
ball ugh you gotta take a dive on that
one brother
wherever christy wants to fence that's
where the fence goes right here on the
range show
[Music]
[Music]
do
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to tim in grand rapids
michigan hey tim what's going on
yes hi how are you outstanding brother
how are you
good i'm just looking for some advice
and i got three teenagers my oldest is
16 youngest is 13. great can we just
stop you there right now um yeah
how are you man
i'm i'm i'm just going to go
that's a lot of teenagers in a little
bitty house brother
yeah
yes
all right so 13 to 16 three teenagers
all right go ahead
um so he wants a car we got him a car
for you know so i can go work in school
i got him like a three four four
thousand dollar car saturday
because his mom wrecked the car that he
was driving a couple weeks prior
everybody's okay just the car's totaled
so we needed to quit get a car so he
could go to school
and work
and then
monday his
sounds like his mom bro bought him a
honda civic were divorced they probably
mentioned that so we don't agree on a
whole lot of stuff
but
so then she knew i was getting this car
she went with me to get it pick it up
look at it
and then monday my other kids i was
dropping him off from school after work
like why didn't he take my car to school
it's like oh he got another one monday
so i'm just trying to so i know he's
there in a lot of debt with the honda
civic i was trying to avoid that that's
why i bought him a cheap
four thousand dollar car so i don't i
don't fully grab it so let me
let me back out and make sure i got it
so you've got a 16 year old son
and you and his mom y'all are divorced
so you took him and bought him a four
thousand dollar car
you agreed with your ex-wife on this and
then she turned around and went and
bought him another car that's nicer
is that right
yes okay
and so what's your question
um i was trying to i was trying to avoid
because keeps paying her back for the
honda civic
so i was trying to avoid
uh him going in debt
if you have a good way to explain
why it's not a good idea to go
20 dollars in debt for a car for a
teenager to understand
so your sixteen-year-old sons having to
pay for this car
yes
how does he feel about that
he thinks it's good because it's a nice
car apparently so
but i just feel i just don't want to
start him out in that one how long has
he had it
monday
i'm gonna throw this out there delaney
you can speak to the relationships
dynamics so much better than i can but
i'll say this i wonder if he would feel
differently after a few months of having
to
pay that payment after he's working
extra hours not getting to use that
money for you know hanging out with his
friends like it's since it's already
been bought
to just let him feel the payment and
then maybe and then maybe you try to
revisit the issue again and say hey like
this you know i mean you talk about how
to communicate it but my mind's asking
about it how do you feel about that well
i don't know i'm just throwing that out
there as an idea because teenagers are
just so stinking short-sighted they're
like all i'm thinking about is who i'm
writing to the football game with friday
night i can't think about the long term
my future even the consequences of this
payment until i feel it and so i just
wonder if that would help him think
about it differently when he has to make
this payment if he really does i don't
know tim is his name on this car or is
your ex-wife's name on this car i i
would have seen the next question
i got to tell you man i i've been doing
this a long time and it's rare that i
just feel that
i get
i get mad in my chest and i got mad on
your behalf i got mad on this little
boy's behalf
because um as you just mentioned teens
are so so short-sighted
i don't want to be i don't want to be
ugly man but
your son's mom is incredibly
short-sighted
and what she's
passing along to him is a number of
lessons here
you you can you if your dad makes a a
recommendation you know what who cares
what dad says let's go do something
different um hey you only have four
thousand dollars to spend let's get a
safe car let's get you to and from now
let's just get a 20 000
the lessons here that he's picking up in
this situation are heartbreaking and so
here's the best you can do tim and this
is this is something that you're gonna
have to do and then you're gonna have to
be the grown up here and set it down
and that is this
you can take your son out for breakfast
you can take someone out for lunch and
y'all just have a private time tell him
like say hey man tell me about this car
he's gonna tell you it's awesome it's
nice and say you know what it is a
really nice car
you can do math 16 year olds don't
always get math you can lay down and say
hey i just want you to see this i'm
giving you this 4 000 car your mom has
done this it's a nice car it is really
nice
you have this option to have no payments
and i want you to then explain i've
chosen to live my life debt free i'm not
chained to anything i can get up and
walk away all those all the things you
know about living a deaf free life
you're not gonna run his mom down you're
not gonna say your mom his your mom's
stupid and she once again you're not
gonna talk crap about her you're gonna
talk about the choices you have made
and then you're gonna tell him man
there's gonna be a lot of friday nights
you're out working it's gonna be a lot
of wednesday nights after school and
tuesdays you're out working it's gonna
be exhausting you're gonna owe your mom
money forever
and after that meeting tim the
conversation's over you can go sell this
car you can let it sit i mean that's up
to you brother you can let that thing
sit but continuing to let it gnaw your
soul while this is gonna happen and his
in his um with his mom when he's staying
with her it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen and so i want you to
clear your your heart on this deal sit
him down and say hey brother this is the
way the right way to i think to be doing
this the way i'm choosing to live my
life your mom obviously has done this
and then you got to put it down you
could be that guy that's like you can't
bring that car to my house and that
that's just putting that's just putting
a wedge between you and your son i
wouldn't do that right what do you think
this is such a this is just
i know i know and and it's just a hard
road for you to walk to him and watch
yeah i think the lesson here that you're
talking about john that is so important
that i want people to get and this is
this is sort of what you're saying
without saying but everybody can can
relate to this
you
are not responsible for your families
financial decisions yeah even when their
parents yeah
not your sister
i mean you have say over your children
that live in your household but even
your adult children you can advise them
you can have that coffee date same with
your parents you can have that coffee
date you can tell them hey here's what
i've done here's what's worked for me
but you cannot let it eat away at your
soul because there's a boundary issue
there of going you are not responsible
you are not in control of what they do
or don't do and you got to let that go
because otherwise it's going to really
weigh you down and i i don't make
your 16 year old son the pawn in the
middle of a
parenting fight between you and your ex
she handed him the keys to a brand new
cool car and he's 16.
and then she
lovingly tagged him with the uh
with the payments to this thing man that
gets me fired up i'm most fired up on
your behalf tim because of the
undermining
because you all too agreed on something
let's do this let's do it this way y'all
went picked out this car and then she
swung one behind your back really
disrespectful yeah it sucks and you're
in a hard situation and so the only
thing you can do in the situation is you
can control your thoughts you can
control your actions you can take the
high road you can treat everybody with
dignity and respect and you can go on
about your day i do if i'm you i am
gonna sit down and have a one-on-one
with my son and say not lecture not you
know what you should be here's what i've
chosen to do with my money and because i
chose to do this with my money i was
able to buy you a four thousand dollar
car with cash you know what i would do
if i were in your shoes tim and i don't
even know that this is right this is
just kind of my gut is um i would have
that conversation like you're saying
over coffee i'd hang onto the car for a
few months yeah and just let it be a
visual of a payment-free life and and
then after a few months if he still
hasn't come around like because he may
he may after i'm telling you after a few
months of consequences you start to
actually care a little bit more in any
age in life by the way but especially
teenagers he might get tired of those
payments work on those friday nights he
might see that car and go yeah mom no
thanks so i don't know i might hang on
to it for a couple months i mean if
assuming it's paid for and cash on all
the things tim it's not you know too big
of a deal for you he may he may just
come around he may just come around i
hope he does here's the meta lesson here
good folks
when somebody
some no matter who you are and and and
where what happened what road you happen
to be walking in life people are going
to undermine you they're going to come
behind your back they're going to look
at your principles for how you're doing
your money how you're doing whatever and
they're going to say that's stupid and
they're going to drop other things in
your lap
at that moment you have a choice
you can go to war and let the bodies
pile up or you can say i'm gonna take
the high road here i'm gonna be the
person of dignity and respect
here's my boundary and i'm gonna walk
this way right and that's the life of
peace there's always moments you gotta
fight we all have to we have to pick
those moments but they're much
they're much rarer than we like to like
to imagine right
tim i'm sorry for you brother take the
high road on this one man
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
delonie joined by christy wright we're
taking your calls on money and life and
relationships and everything in between
let's go to kerry in midland texas my
old stomping ground hey carrie what's
going on
man not a lot how y'all doing we're
doing great brother how can we help
i i got a question and there's a lot of
people out here that have asked me the
same question and i don't know the
answer
we we work in the oil field it is such a
boomer bus you know easter famine that
the baby steps say you save up a
thousand and then you work your way
through all your debt and then you build
your emergency fund for people that have
a job like this that could literally be
over within the next week and be laid
off you should
should you skip or should you swap step
two and three to get to get that
what good is it gonna do me to only owe
ten thousand dollars on my truck if i
don't have a job
okay uh carrie i've got a question
because i know that industry can be um
really you know feast or famine but in
your last
five
to seven years have you gone months and
months without a paycheck
uh i've been laid off three times in the
last seven years yes okay and then
what's the what's the because i i've got
friends who work out in midland odessa
area there what's the good years look
like
uh this year i'll make 190. yeah so i
was thinking they're real good
so how much debt
i tripled my salary come out here what
how much debt do you have
uh about a hundred and eighty and sixty
okay what do you have a hundred sixty
thousand dollars in debt on
i have a truck that had to meet certain
requirements for my work that i get paid
for and then we got rid of our rent
house and everything back home we went
and bought an rv my wife and i live out
here and then she had a truck
do you have debt on that rv
uh yes come on carrie and which what
does she have a truck for
because she needs to she don't like
walking and it's awful hot
that's exactly what i was getting at so
here's the thing
i know i like you gary i
i know you because you're one of my
friends
i know the lifestyle of
the those out there working in the oil
fields
and dude those trucks you line them up
out there and they are trucks of people
who make a hundred and ninety thousand
dollars a year
and then well he does have an i granted
she has an [ __ ] i don't have an
asteroid i'm the work through yes
here's
let me tell you this you make 190
thousand dollars and y'all are broke
you're no no no i didn't say we're broke
no no no i'm telling you brother you're
broke
and here's why i've got about i've got
about 14 000 saved up
you carry you are broke you have a
depreciating asset in an rv that you owe
money on you have a truck that has to
meet work requirements it's a
depreciating asset that you owe money on
your wife is driving some fancy midland
truck and i know exactly the truck it is
and it's a depreciating asset y'all are
broke and you make too much money so to
answer your original question and i know
dude i'm breaking your heart brother and
i would hug you if i was sitting here
with you
if the reason we say a thousand bucks
this is as much a math problem as it is
a psychology problem
i want you to have a thousand dollars
because i want there to be
it is about a tire blew out and i don't
have a used tire that i can afford
because you are not going out to eat
your wife is not driving a sixty
thousand dollar truck you're not
buying a uh
rv on payments you're gonna get one off
craigslist out there
the thousand bucks inspires you to
sprint run you are you are being chased
by lions and you gotta get out of this
debt
and if you only have a thousand dollars
you're not gonna stop and be like ah you
know what let's just go and get that
truck too no you're gonna keep sprinting
and running because yeah you're right a
thousand bucks isn't enough money it's
not it's not enough to float you it's
enough to just duct tape the thing so
you can keep stumbling away because that
line's coming for you coming for you and
coming for you
what y'all have what happens after you
get past that point you know once you
once you do have the money the flat tire
is not going to
be the end of your existence then you
when you're out of debt then you
immediately go to the three to six month
emergency fund
and then then
you you blow out all four tires and it's
annoying it's not a shape shifter you
get laid off and you got six months
emergency fund man then you can go work
at subway for six months until the
market comes back right or you can
i mean what happens if i get laid off
and i still got you know four thousand
dollars a month in banknotes to pay that
that's what i'm telling you only oh ten
thousand dollars left so he doesn't have
any money to pay but he's gotta have an
emergency fund pick it up but carrie
listen your three big debts are all
depreciating assets you're not here what
i'm saying sell your wife's truck today
sell it today
sell your rv today
yo you'll lose money on the rv i'm being
i mean again i'm being a smart aleck
here carrie but you're trying to say hey
we want to keep floating all these big
fancy toys
which is what a giant rv out there is
and what a your wife's fancy truck is
we have all these big fancy toys that we
want to keep floating these things but
then we're nervous we're going to get
laid off yes you should be you should be
freaked out that you're gonna get laid
off because you have so much leverage on
the other side of of your teeter-totter
here
sell everything get out of debt even if
you have to move into a uh a hotel move
into a one-bedroom apartment or trade
that down for the cheapest possible rv
you can have
and then you're telling me you can't
figure it out 190 000 a year you can you
could be out of debt so fast on that
income if you can get rid of some of
these massive like you're saying these
massive debts these massive things that
you don't have to have you need
something your wife does need a vehicle
to get around but she doesn't need the
vehicle that she has and and and that's
what we're saying we're not saying get
rid of these things and you know camp
and walk everywhere we're just saying
downsize it's exactly what we're talking
about earlier of like we upgrade upgrade
and yeah when you in your mind think i
make 190 000 a year i deserve a big
fancy truck if you pay for it in cash by
all means we want you to have those
things but when you're taking out debt
you're actually broke on a really
really good income and you work too hard
and carry the position we want you to
get in
for short term yes downsize cut back
drive embarrassing cars figure out where
you're going all of that but then in the
long term you're going to be in a
position where you make a really good
income and you can have those things but
you don't have that stress so you get
laid off so what because you've got so
much money you're fine and here's the
fun thing about
getting laid off when you have no debt
and you've been making 190 000 for two
cycles
then you go buy that truck from that
person that's got to roll it off because
they're broke and you buy it at half
price
right you go buy a really nice rv
from somebody that's just got to unload
it because they've got 160 000 in
depreciating asset debt and you buy that
rv for half price
that's what we're talking about you got
to survive one bust cycle and all of a
sudden you're on top of this thing in a
really major major way and so what i'm
telling you is yes
sell it man sell everything you got or
get released get rid of your wife's
truck
go bananas paying off your smallest debt
which is probably your truck then go
bananas paying this rv you will not go
to a restaurant you're not going to go
to a movie you're not going to go to a
concert your wife's going to be working
too y'all are going to be out of your
minds on this deal work and work you're
going to pick up extra shifts you're
going to keep going and going and going
and then when you get it laid off which
you will you know how that thing busts
it's going to be annoying and then you
and your wife are going to go on a trip
you're going to take that rv somewhere
and you can go work
it it becomes limitless there's
something about there's something about
that thousand dollar emergency fund
because it's just enough for that tire
like we're talking about that it does
light that fire under you and carrie the
reality is as long as you keep
justifying that debt staying around it's
gonna stay around and you're gonna stay
broke what we're trying to tell you to
do is different it is intentionally
designed to fire you up to be a little
bit scared to get you to work really
hard get rid of this stuff and do
something different so you get a
different outcome you're not going to
get that different outcome by being okay
with these things hanging around where
you're just not and so we're trying to
put you in a position that actually
motivates you to do something different
that's what's going to lead to different
results you made 190 000 this year and
you are
broke
bro you 160 000
and it shouldn't be that way and you
know that man that's why you're calling
and again brother i love you because i
know you you are my friends you're the
guys i went to college with you're the
guys i hung out with you're the guys
that were headed to med school and were
like man i can make way more money out
here i know you carry and that's why i
want to
i want to tell you that i love you
and i want to tell you that there is
peace on the other side of this thing
too going to sleep knowing if i get laid
off tomorrow so what that'll be no big
deal then we're going to get a truck on
discount baby all right thanks so much
for the call carrie hey that's one more
hour in the books we'll be back before
you know it right here on the ramsey
show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your relationships and
everything else i'm dr john dolone
joined here with my good friend
best-selling author and all-around just
good human being christy wright we are
taking your calls on pretty much
anything right anything
triple eight eight two five five two two
five anything that was you said that so
boldly i mean we're here for you
whatever you wanna talk about we
wanna talk to you hey listen before we
get going we got a
a
board full of calls over here kelly's
been working hard um
we're one week out yeah tell us about it
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance it
launches one week from tuesday so that's
september 14th and so that means that
you have one week to go ahead and get
your pre-order for you for a friend
christmas gift whatever but y'all get it
in pre-order because here's why
when you do you get all these free bonus
things so get it and then give your
friend the ebook or the audiobook or
whatever it doesn't matter it helps us
uh hit the list which is it just opens
up doors for opportunity for media and
for marketing and to just uh help more
people which is what we want to do so we
want to say thank you we give you the
ebook audiobook free by the way you know
what something i have not talked about
at all so i'll mention it real quickly
talk about it when i wrote this book i
intentionally designed a free workbook
that goes with it so when you get this
book you get a free workbook that
chapter by chapter has templates for you
to do what i'm telling you to do so for
example in the chapter on creating your
ideal schedule when i walk you through
how to do that the workbook has a
template for how to do that or when i
talk about setting priorities through
workbook has a template so that's a
pretty cool feature that i thought you
know what i don't want people to just
read it cause there's a lot of tactical
steps and takeaways i created a workbook
and the you get it when you get the book
um it's a free digital workbook and so
it just allows you to follow it step by
step one of my reviews that came in
today i was so thankful said
the workbook is the tool you need to do
this it is so valuable blah blah so it
was just really nice and um and yeah so
it i want to help you put this into
action i don't want you just read it i
want you to actually change your life
with it that's why we do what we do so
so can i ask you a question one week
yeah
your hesitation is making me nervous
excited for this question i don't know
which i should you just said create your
ideal schedule yeah
that sounded amazing
you don't know why but i have a spouse
and two little crazy kids they're not
crazy but they're going great
and
i've got an incredibly demanding boss
right
same we share
i've got incredibly demanding co-workers
kelly that's a whole other story right
how do i create my ideal schedule so it
sounds kind of it's ideal within your
current reality it's not ideal in an
alternate reality where you have no kids
and you're living on the beach
that does sound fantastic
but here's the thing and the reason i
walk you through this exercise and this
is a powerful and very common practice
in coaching business and life coaching
but the reason we do is because when you
look at your current schedule
you can't think clearly you're just so
in the weeds of all your commitments and
all the things you're so used to doing
and so you try to move the puzzle pieces
around and you just get overwhelmed and
you end up with maybe a slightly
different mess but you don't question
the mess to begin with and so what i
want you to do is i want you to start
with a blank slate and go okay let me
plot the things i know i have to do okay
i've got work i've got to take the kids
to school these are things i have to do
in my real reality
but then from there you'll be amazed at
how much time you still have to fill
with things that are in line with what's
most important to you right now versus
oh well i've been but i've been doing
that for four years was it still right
for you because it helps you think about
it more clearly and differently when you
start to move things over okay i'm gonna
put things i have to do
then i'm gonna move over things i want
to do that are important and a priority
right now
and then i'm gonna add some new things
that maybe i never had time for before
you and i were talking even during the
break how man some seasons that are hard
can make marriage hard i i personally
experience that it is so hard to stay
connected to mad and have fun with matt
when you just have three kids screaming
in your ears and a book coming out and
speaking engagements and right and yeah
and so matt i just told matt can i have
yeah i know you hate that word it's like
a cuss word to you it is um but it's
like okay well and then let me add let
me add something to the schedule i'm
gonna add thursday night date night
we're gonna get a babysitter and at
least twice a month if not more we're
gonna go on a date night well if i don't
think about that and think about what's
important to me and put it on paper on
purpose then i could go
four months and matt and i don't go on a
date we don't mean to but we're just so
stinking busy with this
mess we live in and we don't question
the mess and so it's just a it's just a
an exercise
to help you look at a different it's not
that you're you're going to go move to
the beach and
neglect your responsibilities but it
does help you think about it with fresh
eye so that's an example
of something that's in the book
everything's very tactical because i
want to take this elusive idea of
balance and break it down to step say
hey if you do this you'll be creating
your version of balance but there are
templates to help you do that because i
think that makes it really actionable i
love love it's valid
valid question man
when you said in your reality then
that's that's that ends up being
something i talk about all the time
right which is
yeah you got to let that fantasy go
that's not the world you live in right
yeah and that could be a number of i
want a husband who i want a wife who it
doesn't exist and and the other piece of
this is if we're not careful and this is
the reason i like this exercise
if we're not careful we feel as if we
are victims to our schedule
and anything on your calendar something
you put there or you allowed to be there
my friend roy vaden said that and i love
that it puts us back in the driver's
seat you're already in control of your
schedule you just need to realize and
live like it so yes there are some real
restraints job taking kids to school etc
outside of that which again you choose
those things as well you know there are
buses there are alternate you know
carpools whatever
christie
it just once you start to realize oh i'm
not a victim i'm in control here then
you begin to design your week your day
your life and connect with your spouse
on it one of the things i have i have
journal questions at the end of the book
and and challenges one of every chapter
connects with your spouse connect to
their spouse what's important to them in
this season what do they want this
season to look like what's their version
of balance look like what boundaries you
know and so this is not um something you
do on your own in a vacuum but man it
brings similar to a budget it brings you
guys together as a team um and then you
realize wow i'm not a victim i can
actually incorporate things that are
most important to me right now and and
just with more intention take control of
my schedule take back your time that's
why i love the title because it's so
active it's like take it
the idea of of
man suddenly you look up and it's been
four years and i just always watch
tv on these two nights and this is the
way bedtime routine has to look with
these kids
this is the what i do when i get home
from work
and suddenly that's 30 minutes here and
45 minutes here and then two hours here
but i don't have time to work out i
don't have time to
write my wife a nice note i don't have
time to do the laundry i can only do it
on saturdays because i don't have time
to start that business i don't have time
i don't have time there's i'm gonna do
it when there's time left over
and then dang it it's been seven years
there's never time left over right right
you don't find time you make time you
make it so if it's important you put on
the calendar and everything's not
important all the time i mean i the one
of the things that i think is so key to
this and this is important for everyone
listening right now especially those of
you guys that are in baby step two i
wanna speak to you right now
everything is not important all the time
this is a season so you need to decide
what makes the cut in this season in
your money and in your time
it's just a season there are things that
don't make the cut right now because i'm
launching a book my house is not that
clean i'm not working out not seeing
friends i did that this summer but in
this season i don't make the cut that's
okay you get to decide what matters to
you in the season you're in and that's
going to help set you free there's
something about just clearing the deck
and saying let's start with a fresh
piece of paper and say what's really
important yep what does this have to
look like
and not what it has what does it have to
look like and then we can get to it love
that you don't find tiny
love it love it love it all right 825
5225 we're taking calls on anything and
everything give us a shout right here on
the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
let's go out to taylor in spokane
washington hey uh yeah taylor hey taylor
what's going on
oh not much how are you guys doing good
hey there's a tyler on on the board too
here so i looked at taylor and i started
to say tyler then i got all confused i'm
sorry man i'm doing this so what's going
on brother how can i help
that's okay well i think you guys might
have already answered my question a
little earlier uh-oh but um that's okay
i'm calling about my wife she's trying
to start a little bit of a business
um
her and i've been married 14 years and
today happens to be her birthday oh
happy birthday to her that's awesome
yeah but she in the last four years um
she's been
developing her art talent and she does
watercolors
custom watercolors portraits
different things anyway
she's tried over the last few years to
develop that a little bit more
but as a stay-at-home mom with four kids
it's kind of tough yeah
to find that that schedule and the
timing
and she's done things like
put it on social media and and uh
you know some of those uh diy cell
websites and whatnot
but uh nothing's really kind of taken
off and it hasn't been the success that
she's wanted it to be
what are the ages of your kids
twelve eleven seven and four
okay and is the four-year-old in any
type of school where she has some time
at home or is she pretty much
with the the four-year-old all the time
um
some of the times she does a co-op
preschool and so she teaches with that
too some of the times so yeah okay well
that's important because if you were
saying you know we have four kids under
age seven then that's a very different
answer than if you've got four kids
where um most of them are in school and
she has some of the time she can block
that on her schedule um here's one of
the things that i would say taylor is um
the the idea of business especially to a
creative
like your wife sounds like she is
especially to someone that's never done
anything in business before it sounds
really intimidating so one of the things
that you can do in real in just a really
supportive way is encourage her in small
steps so it doesn't have to be some big
thing we're going to get it set up and
get logos and make it this big that's
actually super intimidating and you
don't have to do it so just encourage
her like hey like yeah let's put it on
our facebook page hey what if you open
an etsy shop what did you say she's
where has she put it so far
uh she's got it on facebook and etsy and
instagram okay and she's it's just not
uh she's just not getting customers
yeah yeah pretty much okay that can be
super discouraging when you're starting
out because you think oh people don't
like me this is never gonna work see i
knew i wasn't cut out for business um
it's gonna be hard for me to
really uh analyze that without knowing
why you know is it the pricing is it the
messaging is it the you know is it the
product
i don't know but here's what i would
love to do taylor we have a um
event coming up in nashville but it's
also live stream for the business
boutique october 14th through the 16th
so i'd love it if you'll just stay on
the line i'll have kelly
give you a ticket to give your wife
where she can view the live stream we
will talk all about marketing we're
talking about messaging we're going to
give her some specific things she can
take away and apply to what she's doing
and then she'll be able to look at her
facebook posts or or product
descriptions on etsy through the lens of
this uh some of these best practices in
marketing and that type of thing social
media and then also we'll send you a
business boutique book to get her
started before then so she doesn't have
to wait till mid-october to um to start
to learn some of that but i think that
the biggest thing that you can do
is just continue to believe in her and
encourage her and remind her that it's
normal to be slow getting started it's
normal to to learn as you go and figure
out what works and what does it and by
the way every person that's ever been
successful in any type of business has
done that exact same thing that's what
we do here that's what small businesses
do and big corporations do
everybody is starting somewhere and
everyone is figuring it out as they go
learning and adapting and she's just in
the learning phase and that is a super
normal part of the process but the fact
that she has you in her corner is an
awesome thing because that is going to
mean so much to her to believe in her
even when she doesn't believe in herself
taylor and you do and i think that's
awesome so stay on the line and we'll
have kelly give you the business
boutique book and then a ticket to the
business boutique conference for her
whenever you um whenever she can view
that on live stream and hey taylor last
night
um i'll give you the other perspective
here i'm the husband on the other side
of this my wife is
also starting a business
last night
i sat across a table from her and said
it's now we're entering what i would
call the vulnerable season especially
for creatives right it's not a matter of
i just want to start a uh i don't know a
house painting
job
this is i am putting a piece of myself
on a camera
so this is yeah this when they reject
this painting they're rejecting me right
um
i leaned across the table and said how
can i best support you in this season
and what i didn't do was i didn't say
what you should be doing is you should
be doing this and hey you should call
this guy because he's going to help
it was how can i support you in this
season and i'm gonna let her my
brilliant talented wife speak to me and
not try to solve her problems for her
does that make sense
yeah it does i want her to know i'm on
her side but that i'm not trying to
undermine her i don't know her business
or her heart but all those things so i'm
always going to loot back and it's
become a weekly thing how can i support
you now like i said and she's saying i'm
entering vulnerable season now or this
is just business creation season or this
is just how can i support you and i'm
gonna ask her to be honest with me
there's such a great lesson there too
for anybody though for any marriage
conversation around this because often
we think we know what the other person
needs and we go right to that or what we
would want if we were in their shoes but
we're not them and so i love that
there's just there's such a something so
powerful in the simplicity of asking the
person you want to help what type of
help they need how can i help
if your
partner asks you how can i help don't
say nothing
you've got to be honest too right on the
other side yes you've got to tell the
truth and say you know here we go we can
help you yeah all right let's go to
matthew in trenton new jersey what's up
matthew how are we doing
hi thank you for taking my call you bet
man what's up
um so my fiance and i uh moved in
together in july
um and uh i don't have any debt she has
a student loan but she has been uh
crushing her debt for the last uh nine
months she's paid off about forty
thousand dollars so far
um
and
i didn't want um you know pre prior to
living together i was living at home
with my parents and she was wearing all
her parents so you know we're both now
um new until like we're paying bills
we've got rent and um all these all
these payments
um and so i wanted to do a nice thing
and volunteer and say you know what i'm
going to cover
the bills for the next four months
because she's expected to be debt-free
in october and i said you know what i
don't want to derail your debt-free
journey i want to do a nice thing and
help out
and i mean i don't have any debt i have
a good amount of savings i can afford it
the problem is i feel
anxiety spending so much money i'm not
used to that like i said i was living at
home what are y'all getting married man
you're a lot of money
uh next summer next summer
so here's what i want you to do
um have you all started premarital
counseling of any kind
no we have not okay you're both moving
from your parents house
to
um now you're being playing grown-up
okay
and so i want you all to go sit down
with somebody who's going to be a
premarital counselor what's going to do
they're going to pose questions as a
neutral third party
and they are going to teach you guys how
to have these conversations in the
meantime because here's what's going to
happen she's going to feel like your
charity case you're going to feel um
you're going to feel guilty you're gonna
feel weird and suddenly that guilt and
weirdness that's why we tell people man
if you're gonna play house get married
and then put all of your money in the
same account and work together on this
deal because what you're doing now is
you're trying to do both things here
you're trying to practice living
together you're trying to practice the
money thing and then you're gonna have
all these interconnected feelings and
drama and then you're gonna it's gonna
be her fault and your your fault it's
gonna become a mess real quick you're
already feeling that right
yeah yeah exactly so and by the way
you're gonna take the way you did it at
your house and that's the only way you
know and she's going to take the way she
did at her house and there's going to be
this
it's going to be a mess and so if you're
going to wait a whole year to get
married i mean you're already there i'd
say go find somebody this weekend just
to the piece and get this thing done and
then you dump it all in the same account
and go for it if you're not going to do
that
then i want you to go get a
pre-marital counselor and you all start
walking through
some actual steps that you can take to
make sure you're having the right
conversation you're staying on the same
page and y'all are learning how to
become teammates because man you're
trying to change the oil in this car
while it's driving down the road at 85
miles an hour and you can flip this
thing if you're not careful okay
don't get over dramatic go meet with
somebody and y'all start walking through
these plans together we'll be right back
on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lines.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from bianca in
arizona she asks
my boyfriend of four years and i
recently started listening to your
podcast and have been working on a
budget and our debt snowball i know you
recommend not paying off your boyfriend
or girlfriend's debt if you're not
married but my boyfriend insists on
paying off my debt to move us closer to
marriage and a family however when he's
upset about our spending he starts by
saying if it weren't for me helping you
christy i don't like this dude this
makes me hesitant about allowing him to
do anything for me and it's starting to
weigh me down how should i handle this
situation i think they should go see the
premarital counselor that matt and i saw
them make her think twice
you haven't walked in the aisle yet um
i don't like i don't like that attitude
i don't like it at all
i don't like your ass it's not a gift if
you're gonna hold it over my head
aside from the other issues it there are
so many issues i just want to highlight
that one it's the gasoline power
nonsense i don't like it at all you need
me you need me here's a gift
what do you mean it's i'm running this
uh bianca i would tell you to run run
run
but you got four years invested and so i
know that would be a snap judgment based
off something i'm just reading here and
i haven't um ever met you
but
this is why one of the one reason why we
tell you don't pay off your boyfriend or
girlfriend's debt because you're not
married you're not in this whole thing
together there's still some lucy goose
here and you're finding out something
about your boyfriend that's really
powerful which is
he's gonna consider things a gift and
then hold it over your head
right and by the way
having debt doesn't keep you from
getting married and starting a family in
fact you all do that together as part of
your journey together right
i don't like any of this so i think
you're actually we're joking but i think
you're right you need to go see a
premarital account a pre-marriage
counselor today right
i have so many questions if she if if
she's working on her debt i assume she's
at least in her
early 20s i mean this is a major
assumption here so maybe not but i'm
going i don't know unless you're super
young you know i'm maybe you're in the
mid late 20s at least you're super young
why why haven't y'all gotten married yet
four years why haven't i got married yet
unless you know like i said unless
you're second thing i love how she said
um
he
insists on paying my debt to move us
closer to marriage and a family let me
tell you how you move it close your
family you put a ring on it
that's how you move us closer to
marriage and you could you could do that
you don't have to pay off the debt first
again what jumps out to me
in this
is the and it's in quotes so she's
quoting him i'm guessing here if it
weren't for me helping you
i don't like this power dynamic
i don't like the dynamic i don't like
the control i don't like the attitude
and here's the thing if he's acting like
this now bianca i know you thought you
were asking a money question if he's
acting like this now when you're not
married
i don't want to see the version of him
when he thinks he has more authority as
your husband and mother
like it so here's something bianca you
say it here and i'm going to reiterate
your own words back to you
this makes me hesitant about allowing
him to do anything for me
including be my husband including make
humans with me
right and it's starting to weigh me down
yes you said it those are your words i
love how you said that those are her
words those are your words and i want
you to listen to what you wrote
read what you wrote you can't listen to
what you wrote re-read what you wrote
your your instinct feels correct to me
the um
one of the most beautiful
and difficult
and beautiful aspects of marriage
is being vulnerable this is the person
you're the most vulnerable with of
anybody else and a one of a beautiful
gift in marriage is allowing your your
spouse to do things for you and them and
vice versa and and you do and you will
have to there are times matt has seen me
of my lowest lowest lows and my worst
worst worst worst worse
and um that's a gift to get to go
through the worst of the worst times
with the person you love the most
as they carry you when you're at your
worst and you carry them when you're at
their worst that's trust that's what
that is that's trust and you don't have
that bianca
and he's not proven worthy of it you're
right in your assessment that you're
hesitant about allowing him to do
anything i don't like it and i want to
speak to the other
side if you are somebody
who gives a gift
if you are somebody who's helping
somebody through a tough time
don't ever say if it weren't for me
don't ever say but without me you
wouldn't be
it's a gift
and if you use kindness and weaponize it
as a as a tool to get power if you
um
show up with food as an roi that uh
they're gonna owe you later
what a sad way to live
if you're gonna give a gift give a gift
if you're going to
commit and say hey i'm gonna i we've
agreed for whatever reason i don't agree
with it but if we've agreed we're not
going to get married we're not going to
start a family till we're out of debt
and i'm going to help you out
then help out
and shut your mouth help out
if it weren't for me helping you if
there's strings attached it's not a gift
if you bring it up again there's it's
not a gift and really what and i love
how you called out this side of people
because i've known people like that i
get it here's the thing if you bring it
up again it's not a gift if there's
strings attached it's not a gift and
what you're saying and what you're
showing
is that this is about you
what a hero you are what a big dog you
are that you can do xyz and you're using
it as a weapon of manipulation and power
and control and and no one likes that
and and no one wants to be around that
yeah no one wants your gift there's not
a gift in the world there's not an
amount of money in the world that would
make me
jump for someone saying that i'm going
to hold this over your head i'm like
cool i'll walk bye felicia i'm out we go
we go there's nothing that's going to
yeah all right let's see if tyler and
sacramento can redeem this segment i'm
just starting to get my blood pressures
up tyler what's up
what's up guys thanks for taking my call
tyler save the segment here man i'm
getting all frustrated what's up help us
okay okay so i'm 26 and my wife and i
have been married for a year we got
married during the pandemic and um
we started doing the dave ramsey baby
steps we're on baby step two um the only
the only debt that we have is our
student with my student loans but i
guess ours ours there you
go i'm trying i'm trying to redeem it
and um we have older cars so they were
but wine was gifted to me by my grandma
i didn't have to pay for it and my
wife's her parents helped her pay for it
and they're a little bit older they're
kind of reaching like really high
mileage and so i guess the question that
i have for you guys is
how should we approach replacing
probably my wife's car when that time
comes while we're paying debt do we
like take our student loans and like
pause them and then save up for a couple
months to buy like a used car that'll
keep us going do we just try to use one
car
we both work and my wife goes to school
and i work full time how much how much
debt
we have about five thousand forty eight
forty five to forty five forty eight
thousand student loans um and we have
our thousand dollars saved up but we
also have a little bit of overage for
savings because we just started doing
this uh recently
um and so we were just trying to figure
out should we just throw all of that how
much do you make
how much you make man
before uh taxes together we make about
76 000. okay when will you be out of
debt have you all tracked that
yeah so it just depends on how much we
we put down so i collected like right
now if we don't change anything
about uh two and a half years but um i
just started doing a side hustle so
whatever money i make from that i plan i
just put it towards that so i mean
realistically maybe in about two years
we could be able to here's the deal
tyler um you can do it faster
i want you and unless that car
completely stops moving you're not going
to replace it
i want baby step two is designed for
this
you are a
a gazelle hanging out on the planes and
a lion pops out of the grass and is
chasing you to kill you
you have a thousand dollars and that
thousand bucks is for absolute
emergencies you're going to take any of
your other savings you're going to vote
at this student loan debt and you're
going to work two side hustles on top of
a third side hustle and you are going to
beat the life of these cars you're going
to beat it right so no you're not gonna
save up for cars if one falls apart
you're gonna buy a thousand dollar car
this is gonna get you from a to b until
you can get out of debt and say but for
another one right the goal here is to
scratch claw and sprint your way to pay
these things off 18 months max probably
15 months if you'll really hurry and
then you start saving up for cars
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is psalm 16
8.
i have set the lord always before me
because he is at my right hand i shall
not be shaken
booker t washington says character not
circumstance
makes the person
who say that one again
character
not circumstance makes the person
booker t my man all right let's go to
susan in detroit hey susan what's going
on
hi guys how are you outstanding how can
we help
um thank you so much for taking my call
to my favorite ramsay personality right
that's what we've been saying susan
you're our favorite you're our favorite
i'm hoping you guys can help me i'm a
little bit um and short i feel like i
i lost my mojo and i'm trying to get it
back where'd it go where'd it go
i don't know
so
[Music]
the quick and dirty version is that
i am
my youngest our youngest child uh will
be graduating high school in two years
and so
um i have been
primarily a stay-at-home mom for the
past seven years um
accidentally it was not the plan but it
was kind of god's plan and that's the
way it worked out um so that's okay but
basically um i originally had plans to
go to law school right out of undergrad
um but i met my husband and we married
right out of undergrad and he's ex-navy
so i ended up following him through his
military career
well now we're at the point where um our
youngest kid is getting ready to
graduate and
my resume
because i've been primarily a
stay-at-home mom it looks like the
resume of a military spouse so
um i've got a little bit of everything
here and there but i'm really wanting to
move forward and kind of get back on
that path to doing what i
um want to do career-wise for me and i
am concerned about whether or not i'm
moving in the right direction because
i'm torn between
law school and entrepreneurship
and i'm trying to find a way to merge my
passions and my interests and still
um
and not waste money because we're also
on baby step two how old are you susan
i am 46. 46. susan
for the first time
in a long time
you get to think about what just you
want to do
that's a big deal
like this is a really special moment in
time
that you get to think about what you
want to do
and that can be really exciting
it can also be super overwhelming
because maybe it's law school which was
the dream a long long time ago and maybe
it's something totally new
and totally different
and what's so what's so cool about this
moment is that
you have a ton of options
you don't have to make the decision
tomorrow
and
you have permission to try some stuff
you don't have to it doesn't have to
feel like this huge big commitment i'm
definitely going to do this and commit
and put all this money behind the
scissors you can spend some time just
figuring it out
figuring out what you
enjoy what's life giving testing
experimenting trying some stuff
and so i just i just want to encourage
you you're at a really special moment
and i have i have seen friends go
through this moment where their kids are
in school
and it can be exciting it can also be
terrifying
but i just want to encourage you that
the possibilities are endless and you
don't have to commit today
right now to what the one thing you're
going to do in this new season is you
can test and experiment so susan you may
have heard me tell this story before and
but i i like telling it so i'll do it
again
at 43
42 or 43 maybe 44.
my mom took her first community college
class a couple of miles from my
childhood home
and i think that we took algebra
together sounds like your kids are ahead
of me we took i was a freshman in high
school we either took algebra together
or geometry or something
she took one class
in the next semester she took one more
class
and then the next semester she took two
and she had my dad cheering her on
she had a couple of us we were still
trying to figure things out because
suddenly we were doing the laundry on
her own and figuring stuff out as we
were going
right
at age 57 after working at enron
deloitte touch and some fancy pants
places she graduated with her phd and
became an english professor
and at 70 she just rolled off to go back
to be a professor after being a
department chair
this is a woman who would not get on an
airplane who's now spent the last decade
flying to wales and oxford and t being a
professor all over the world
and that started at 43 or 44.
and so here's the thing
take one community college class just
one
and if you don't like it it costs you 59
an a credit hour
right that's a that's a fancy dinner
and you can take one class and say
man law school is not for me i was also
the dean of students at a law school i
had multiple students who were second
career folks in their 30s 40s 50s and
they're in law school classes with 22
year olds and it makes for a really
wacky dynamic but you know what they are
after three years lawyers
right
that's what they are yeah
so here's the question you have to ask
yourself
at age 50 which you're going to be
do you want to be a lawyer at age 50 or
not
do you want to have an associate's
degree in a new thing or not you want to
have a small business or not those are
the magic questions are they scary yes
but i'll tell you you can change your
entire
here's what here's what that allowed me
to do can i tell you something crazier
it allowed me at my early 40s when i had
accomplished my dream job at my dream
university
to say i'm gonna do something crazy and
take a complete left turn and come work
for this wacky crew here at ramsey
solutions and here you are so that's
that one decision
changed an entire legacy in a home right
it gave all of my mom's kids permission
to just follow our noses do the next
right crazy thing to be tethered in etc
etc
susan one thing
stay on the line too because
ken coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose in the beginning of that book he
walks you through how to really get
clear in what you'd want to do and i
think that would be really helpful for
you in this season and he has the path
to help you pursue it and then
as well i'll have kelly send you a copy
of business boutique if you do decide to
go the small business route or even a
side business like delaney and are
saying you can experiment one community
class and maybe work on something on the
side and just test some of these things
to see what
makes you light up and come alive and
that you want to pursue at a low risk
level so stay on the line i'll have
kelly send you uh or gets you
pre-ordered for ken's new book that
comes out in november my new book that
comes out next week or the next week and
um and as you get those in your hands
those just gives you some tools to start
walking you through some questions to
ask yourself to get clear on what that
looks like for you in this journey and
one last thing to not forget susan and
actually it's not just not just for
susan this is for everybody
when your kids are becoming
sophomores juniors seniors
it's gonna feel like you have a hole in
your heart that is just getting bigger
and bigger and that's just called grief
it's just called sadness because your
kid's moving on and you miss those
little days i told my daughter last
night she's five she has permission no
more to keep growing she's as tall and
as big as she's allowed to be that's it
we're done that's it and she said my
birthday's coming and we're gonna have
cake and when i have cake then i become
six and that's just how that works
it's okay to feel sad and to begin
making plans at the same time right
you're not crazy or nuts or bananas if
you are if your heart's broken your
kid's going to college you've been a
stay-at-home mom this is the thing right
it's gonna have a season you're gonna
have a season of grieving and a season
of excitement and a season of this is so
scary and a season of dipping your toe
in the water or jumping all in or all of
it all at the same time and so it's
going to feel overwhelming so make sure
you got a crew of people that's going to
walk through this with you make sure you
got two or three women that you trust
that you can text and say am i crazy and
they'll go yeah but keep going anyway
right that you're going to have a gang
because it's going to be all of this all
at the same time and then man at 50
years old susan's gonna call us and be
like what's up suckers do you all need
some legal representation gonna be so so
good so so good what are you gonna do at
43 christie oh my gosh
i am not as much of a planner as you
think i am i'm like let me get through
the next 43 minutes
11 kids under three that's right i do
have 11 kids i have three kids but it
feels like 11 and
yeah it's just it's like what i'll tell
you my hope i wrote this down this
morning when i was journaling my hopes
for this season is that i can be fully
present for it it's easy to be so
exhausted with little kids or anybody in
a hard season that you wish it away i
don't wanna wish it away i wanna be
right where i am be where your feet are
wherever you are be there don't wish it
away big thanks to ben on the boards and
to kelly daniel they're taking the calls
it's good to see your smiling faces
staring back at us and thank you america
for being with us we'll see you soon
right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789.
[Music]
you